inertie forte unie président de
l'assemblée nationale catalane en france
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir une assise forte unie merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france pour les
indépendantistes cette situation
sanitaire ne compromette elle pas leur
chance de s'unir
eh bien je pense que ce n'est pas
tellement la situation la crise
sanitaire parce que le tout dans tout
état de cause malgré la crise sanitaire
on a organisé aujourd'hui dans la
journée dans pratiquement toutes les
villes de catalogne 137 actes en
respectant de tous les toutous les
distances et les impératifs duo covit 19
mai
ces actions ont été faites et ces
manifestations étaient faites dans le
cadre de l'unité
bien entendu il est normal dans tout
mouvement qu'il y ait des divergences
stratégiques
c'est normal mais il ya quand même le
point commun qui rassemble tout le monde
c'est celui de la création et la
fondation d'une république catalan et
c'est la raison pour laquelle le débat
et les discussions pour l'unité de la
catalogne vont bon train malgré tout
vous parler maintenant de l'unité de la
catalogne est ce qu il est toujours
question d'indépendance on le sait aussi
il y à une guerre des chefs en tout cas
entre les talents et tenant d'une ligne
dure et les autres il ya oui
l'indépendance départ ça c'est le point
commun tous le mouvement indépendantiste
c'est à dire que tout le monde est
d'accord sur la république catalan ce
qui ce qui change c'est justement les
questions stratégiques
il y a des une partie de
l'indépendantisme qui pensent qu'il faut
aller vers une confrontation
intelligente comme l'a précisé le
président en exil à bruxelles qui est
député européen également en expliquant
cette cette confrontation intelligente
dans la mesure où l'état espagnol ne
croient pas au dialogue puisque l'état
espagnol ne veut pas de dialogue
et d'ailleurs il a été impossible
jusqu'à l'heure actuelle 2 2
fixer un ordre du jour et le
gouvernement espagnol refuse de se
mettre d'accord sur un ordre du jour une
partie de l'indépendantisme pense qu'il
faut être plus plan dans le processus et
convaincre davantage de des catalans
pour pour pouvoir voter et organiser le
référendum
donc il ya ces divergences ce stratège
stratégique mais ce ne sont pas des
différences de fond mais sur le ni sur
les objectifs sur ce plan là il ya une
unité totale de tout le mouvement
indépendantiste
donc les mêmes objectifs les moyens d'y
parvenir peut-être d'y faire on sait que
carl f puisque des mandats qui est vous
l'avez dit en belgique actuellement veut
former un nouveau mouvement c'est
possible selon vous oui absolument
c'est à dire qu'il y a il faut
l'explication de ce nouveau mouvement
provient en grande partie de l'histoire
des partis politiques récents en
catalogne il est il est vrai aussi que
ramon si bien il est s'est éteint le
candidat du parti des démocrates de
catalogne
il est vrai aussi qu'aujourd'hui
rassemble un mouvement beaucoup plus
large que woods amon rassemble des gens
de gauche rassemble des gens de centre
gauche des gens de centre droit et que
par conséquent il est normal qu'il y ait
des tensions et qu' une partie de ce
parti n'est pas vous souhaitez élargir
ce large mouvement qu'il a créé du nom
de
ensemble pour la catalogne et que par
conséquent on sait je pense que il a eu
l'air raison quelque part puisque dans
500 projets 20 dans le sens de l'unité 1
de l'indépendantisme et puis une
nouvelle donne dans ce contexte
sanitaire c'est la formation d'un
gouvernement de coalition en espagne
avec pedro sanchez toujours à sa tête
mais fragilisée oui c'est un c'est 1,5
c'est ça son gouvernement socialiste en
alliance avec podemos a toujours hâte de
tout temps depuis le début n'a pas la
majorité absolue au parlement espagnol
ce qui l oblige à rechercher des
alliances il a été d'ailleurs été élu
grâce au soutien des indépendantistes
catalans faute de quoi ils nord il ne
leur pas été mais en même temps c'est
quelqu'un en qui on ne peut pas faire
trop confiance puisque il essaye surtout
de deux convaincants les
indépendantistes catalans qu'il est prêt
au dialogue etc
mais en fait son sol son sol but est
tout simplement d'obtenir une certaine
stabilité politique
mais dès qu'il a obtenu six tables cette
stabilité politique commirent la
recherche à l'heure actuelle pour le
vote du budget de 2021
une fois il a il obtient cette stabilité
politique du moins pendant pendant
quelque temps automatiquement
il est il remet en cause le dialogue est
illettrée extrêmement difficile nous on
la plupart du mouvement indépendantiste
catalan ne croient pas au dialogue parce
que nous pensons que l'espagne ne veut
pas dialoguer parce que en outre
dialogue sans négociation n'a aucun sens
qu'est ce que ça veut dire dialoguer en
discussions du café de commerce sinon ce
n'est pas ça une négociation la
négociation ça veut dire un ordre du
jour avec des points essentiels et nos
points essentiels c'est d'une part la
reconnaissance du droit à
l'autodétermination
l'organisation d'un référendum et la
mystique de tous les prisonniers
politiques
et bien entendu l'arrêt de la répression
qui continue de plus belle bien entendu
aujourd'hui on n'arrête plus les les
hommes politiques de premier plan
l'addition des gens ont pris
mais on arrête des hommes politiques et
des hauts fonctionnaires de deuxième
plan et notamment aussi ils sont en
train il ya un procès d'inégibilité
contre le président actuel de la
catalogne
parce que tout simplement ils avaient
mis une pancarte sur la façade du siège
du gouvernement en demandant la liberté
des prisonniers politiques
or il a été poursuivi et il va passer en
devant la cour suprême de madrid qui au
demeurant c'est un tribunal qui fait la
pluie et le beau temps en matière
politique en espagne ce qui n'est pas
normal
il ya en cause de ça il ya plus de
séparation de pouvoir en espagne
donc le président actuel de la catalogne
risque d'être déclarée inéligible
le 17 septembre ce qui va l'obliger à
démissionner de ses fonctions et de sans
doute de convoquer de nouvelles
élections au parlement de catalogne ce
qui est à notre avis intolérable dans la
mesure où que pour une simple pancarte
ans déclare inéligibles le président de
la catalogne nous paraît une
intromission intolérable de la justice
espagnole dans la politique très courts
et niati fortune isf qui a eu un impact
de la crise sanitaire on sait que la
catalogne a été durement éprouvée
l'espagne d'ailleurs en général est ce
que ça me ça fragilise le pouvoir à
madrid et la perception des catalans
envers le pouvoir central je pense que
il faut tenir compte aussi c'est que la
situation de l'espagne est extrêmement
complexe à l'heure actuelle le problème
catalan n'est qu'une facette dix ans de
cette crise institutionnelle que l'on
vit en espagne notamment du fait qu' il
y avait vu une crise de la monarchie il
y à une crise du système politique à une
crise économique aggravée par le par la
pandémie et il ya une crise
territoriales très forte
il est notamment le fait que il ya aussi
une corruption qui n'a pas l'air de
vouloir être résorbé que
la corruption continue de plus belle en
dans toute l'espagne
donc tous ceux ci ce sont des éléments
de fragilisation de gouvernement qu'ils
soient socialistes ou une autre couleur
politique
la situation en espagne est fragile ce
qui en même temps
pardon merci beaucoup il n'y est si
forte unie merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rtl france